dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly affair
the faithful simulation of human skin is
incredibly important both in computer
games the movie industry and also in
medical sciences the appearance of our
face is strongly determined by the
underlying structure of our skin human
skin changes significantly with age it
becomes thinner and more dry while the
concentration of chromophores the main
skin pigments diminishes and becomes
more irregular those pigment
concentrations are determined by our age
gender skin type and even external
factors like for example exposition to
UV radiation or our smoking habits as we
age the outermost layer of our skin the
epidermis thins the melanin Hamre globin
and water concentration levels drop over
time as you could imagine having a
plausible simulation considering all the
involved actors is fraught with
difficulties scientists at the
university of zaragoza came up with a
really cool fully fleshed bio physically
based model that opens up the
possibility of simply specifying
intuitive parameters like age gender
skin type and get after some processing
a much lighter skin representation ready
to generate photorealistic rendered
results in real time luckily one can
record diffusion profiles also called
scattering profiles that tell us the
color of light that is reflected by our
skin in this image above you can see a
rendered image and the diffusion profile
of a 30 and an 80 year old person the
idea is the following
you specify intuitive inputs like age
and skin then run a detailed simulation
once that creates these diffusion
profiles that you can use forever in
your rendering program and all this is
done in a way that is biophysically
impeccable I was sure that there was
some potential in this topic but when I
first saw these results they completely
crushed my expectations excellent piece
of work thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time